infinity is one of the last names you
think of when talking about compact cars
but now the luxury division of Nissan
Renault is indeed entering this segment
albeit with a little help from a rival
lemus a car review recalls the old
saying that you can't pick your family
that's not quite true in the automotive
world infiniti has embarked on a
collaboration with Daimler to jointly
develop new models the q30 is a kind of
twin brother of the a-class although
from the exterior it looks completely
different thank God the q30 bosa
designed more radical than anything else
in the class its body is replete with
curves increases standing one metre 48
tall the q30 is head to head with a
Mercedes GLA the latter does have more
cargo space though with the Infinity
packing in just three hundred sixty
eight litres with the back seat up a lot
of contacting sill is at a convenient
level so you don't have to bend too much
and the trunk is nice and wide the only
minor disappointment is the slightly
stiff tailgate mechanism but otherwise
it's a very practical car the materials
deployed for the interior are certainly
up to the brands luxury standards the
front cabin has an original design but
does also include a lot of parts taken
from Mercedes
and from the engines to the four-wheel
drive available with some additions
everything comes from the a-class the
q30 sport with a 155 kilowatt 2-liter
turbocharged engine will set you back at
least forty thousand euros
dec will devise a schism for the q30 is
a little higher than most other compact
cars explains online shifting it towards
the crossover segment that means you can
always keep your eye on the road thanks
to the high seating position you always
have a nice view of the double wave hood
and always have a sound feel of how long
the car is upfront otherwise the
handling is comfortable enough without
feeling too soft English seems
comfortable one of the by vocalist
rummaged through the suspension in the
sports version is seven percent stiffer
than the regular edition the designers
at infinity also ensured there'd be the
right suspension setup for the varying
engine weights that integrated approach
to development is intended to translate
into a superior driving experience and
listen it a bit of SUV a bit okupe in a
bit of Mercedes sound combination says
Andre and with this low entry price
they're getting a lot of car for your
money that price is just over
twenty-four thousand euros in Germany
but the basic version does include
manually operated climate control and a
forward collision warning system with
emergency braking
if you like foggy wondering why our
Carmen Montes is wearing a woolly hat
and scarf in the car it's because when
he's driving a convertible he wants the
roof down no matter how cold it is
outside he just needs to reduce his
speed 250 kilometres an hour while
opening the roof then kind of hear that
stock off huh it takes 12 seconds to
open up the Jaguar f-16 after nearly 40
years the British Marquis has finally
come up with a worthy successor to the
legendary e-type Jaguar long had plans
to build this car but it wasn't until
2013 that it finally went ahead when it
comes to looks the f-type has got to be
one of the sleekest roadsters around
elenco modest likes the responsive
steering the suspension has the furnace
you'd expect from a sports car but on
long journeys on uneven roads it could
get a bit strenuous after a while da is
a standard van Gogh dancer lunch date
hookah fed me of--this likes the way the
instrument display is set out the
steering wheel has a sound grip yes sir
yeah this hand hold here is not really
any use to the driver it's presumably
there for the passenger to hold on when
the driver decides to put their foot
down the exterior is clearly inspired by
the classic e type with a trademark
elegant shape but the hood and the
radiator grille aren't just a straight
copy instead Jaguar has gone for a more
modern interpretation the door handles
disappear smoothly into the bodywork the
interior exudes that classic British
understatement three elegant dials take
care of all the various on board
functions giving an uncluttered feel the
hood opens forwards just like the e-type
revealing in this case a 3-liter v6
engine
it delivers 280 kilowatts of power and
takes 5.1 seconds to go from 0 to 100
km/h jaguar says the f-type uses an
average 8.9 litres of fuel for 100
kilometers and emits 211 grams of co2
per kilometer that I fleet the devil is
always in the detail and Montes has
noticed a few things that unfortunately
don't quite match his expectations of
such an expensive car firstly there's
this little seam here on the door then
the volume control for the radio the
knob is made of the same hard plastic as
the other knots so you have to press
quite hard to turn it without slipping
that under the incontinent Miss
approached how efficient the paddle
shifts on the steering wheel aren't so
nice either you could feel they've been
put together with two simple pieces of
plastic Jaguar could have found a more
elegant solution there
if markets dozen of my dustox montes is
now going to close the roof thanks to
the interior heating and heated seats
it's actually quite okay to drive in
cooler temperatures but the noise level
is something else I can come one does
this take a voyage pig my mother's from
particularly if you like to drive fast
and for longer periods it might be worth
getting some earplugs otherwise it's
hard to bear for very long headphones on
sneaky Lana
he's been yard today Montes has been
testing the f-type with a 6-cylinder
engine it's also available with eight
cylinders but if you just want to have
fun and cruise around the countryside
but also on a powerhead sometimes he
thinks the six-cylinder unit is just
fine
Mercedes has introduced a coupe a
edition of the c-class the AMG version
now has an even more dynamic look and
performance it's powered by a 4-liter v8
biturbo engine that generates 350
kilowatts and if that's not sporty
enough for you you can order the AMG s
version and that comes with an extra 25
kilowatts the eco sport originally built
in Brazil has been given a major
makeover the changes were made by four
to cater to customer demands the latest
edition will feature a new look and feel
at the wheel as well as updated
engineering and connectivity at the same
time the suspension has been adapted to
European road conditions
vinta life does I know Dyson / says many
people are unsure whether they really
need winter tires they might live in a
city where it doesn't snow and be put
off by the cost of a second set of tires
so our winter tires necessary or not
bear in mind that the rubber compound
and summer tires begins to harden as
soon as temperatures dip close to zero
which can reduce traction considerably
winter tires stay soft and offer more
grip in cold conditions zine goddess
that I note says you should switch to
winter tires when daytime temperatures
drop to seven degrees Celsius over 24
hours temperatures can dip considerably
below that level for example early in
the morning or late at night and that
affects driving safety winter tires are
necessary in parts of northern
continental Europe for example from
October through a stir you don't need a
professional to change tires by the way
with a good jack and right tools you can
do it yourself first loosen the wheel
nuts about a quarter of a turn when the
tires are still touching the ground and
jack up one wheel at a time while it's
in the air you can remove the wheel nuts
and the wheel
winter tires need to be fitted for all
four wheels if you don't your car is
likely to start skidding when you pull
up sharp when you're tightening the
screws work diagonally from one to the
next so that the wheel doesn't become
misaligned you also have to check the
torque values with a torque wrench to
make sure the nuts are tightened to full
pressure if you drive with summer tires
when it's cold there is not just the
risk of skidding your braking distances
will also be significantly increased and
not just in wet snowy or icy conditions
all if I talk about how at low
temperatures you need further to break
with summer tires even when it's dry
it's worse when roads are wet and cold
if you're traveling at 90 km/h and at 0
degrees Celsius braking distances
increased by 5 meters 40 centimeters the
entire length of a car when there's snow
on the ground stopping distances
increase by 42 meters motor racing fans
know that slicks offer maximum traction
and dry conditions but car treads that
are worn smooth are dangerous in wet and
snowy conditions if winter tires have
less than four millimeters tread their
performance is drastically reduced
the NZ members on the school you're the
difference between summer and winter
tires is particularly obvious as high
note the surface of the winter treads
are covered with jag and slits designed
to grip snow and ice summer tires need
to cope with high speeds and also expel
as much water as possible so that
they're also safe in damp or wet driving
conditions now such like a co two veeks
Anka did I think it look having your
tires inflated to the right pressure is
equally important for both types if
they're not fuel consumption and where
increase as does the danger of blowouts
checking your tire pressure doesn't cost
anything and it's very important each
wheel has to support a quarter of the
vehicles wait our stay at Lyon can weigh
up to 500 kilos fully loaded it's not
the rubber but the air that bears the
load if there's not an affair the stress
on the tire walls is so great that the
tire can burst we have them Conan want
done get us some see how it's really
cool but there's nothing to stop us
using our winter tires in the summer is
there jump think again says line hook
winter tyres have lower speed ratings
and the soft rubber compound is also a
disadvantage when temperatures rise if
it's warm and rainy you're more likely
the skid with winter tires than summer
once and stopping distances are also
longer yep I'm speak is now if lenghas
mesomorph
BMW has given it c 650 GT and c 650
sport a facelift the changes in the c
650 sport are largely limited to the
design new lights at the front and the
slim figure aimed to give the maxi
scooter well sporty-er look the c 650 GT
now comes with a new safety feature it's
already familiar to the car sector but
its introduction to the two wheeler
world sees BMW breaking new ground
Benzema watts reporter off knows from
experience that motor bike or scooter
riders bend forward when turning this is
in order to try to compensate for the
blind spot in response BMW decided to
give one of the two scooters a new side
view assist ralph wants to find out
whether this is just a gimmick or
whether it makes sense and might soon be
seen in motorbikes to Ghani atticus
gimmick orders this absolute sinful
incredible Shinawatra return home at
speeds of between 25 and 80 km/h the
side view assister SVA and forms the
writer of any other vehicles within a
five metre vicinity the system then
flashes up a warning triangle on the
mirror stock of the c 650 GT
upon the mobility the feature is ideal
for urban condition says BMW motorbikes
executive Michelle Haim wat you have
frequent Lane changing and high traffic
density which is where the feature can
help prevent accidents the built-in
sensors and a control module or in the
right positions as is the warning
triangle in the stock of the mirror I
got something in the GT which ralphs
took for a ride packs a two-cylinder
in-line engine with 44 kilowatts it
makes the sprint from 0 to 100 km/h in
seven and a half seconds abs and
automatic stability control our standard
fitted when matsumoto at ralphs urges
motorbike riders who scoff at larger
scooters like this new BMW c 650 GT to
try one first yes there are features
that really are taboo okay features the
body footprints and hide it grips heated
seat and the continuously variable
automatic transmission are not normally
associated with motorbike riding but
this scooter offers plenty of comfort
great wind protection and really packs a
punch a two-cylinder engine tilted
forward by 70 degrees has a far better
response which ralphs really appreciates
in city traffic the suspension is more
sensitive and in general you really
notice the technical advances this is
more than just a visual facelift geetika
in the tub the design of the c 650 GT
has seen only minor modifications
compared to the preceding model there's
a new rear lamp cluster for example on
the practical side an adjustable
windshield powered by a handlebar
mounted switch also new is the automatic
date i'm riding light in this mode if
the bike registers light conditions
falling below a certain level it will
automatically switch from daytime to low
beam
ultimix hidden riding around on the
streets of Valencia has given Ralph the
chance to check out the main new feature
besides you assist it's basically a
blind spot alert which many people say
is too much for a two wheeler but ralph
was glad to have it on board it's no
replacement for looking over your
shoulder of course but it really does
boost safety when you need to switch
lanes fast in city traffic Ralph could
well imagine this being introduced for
motorbike soon as well state now
undistinguished and Optus biden matura
and convert
a look now at an iconic car that has a
huge following car tester Christophe
Bauer is out and about and a Volkswagen
Beetle convertible exploring the
mountain plateau of ladder wony in Italy
the beetle cabriolet was manufactured
right up until nineteen eighty it was
first designed back before the Second
World War Christophe says these days the
convertible is the epitome of freedom
and independence but in the 1930s things
were different those who could afford it
but a hardtop sedan preferably with a
chauffeur there were always soft tops
but they tended to be very basic and
quite a bit cheaper so the beetle which
was always intended as a car for the
masses obviously planned to have a
convertible right from the start fun fun
and cobb yoga plant at it
the first prototype for the soft-top
beetle was built in nineteen thirty-six
although series production would not
follow for many years after the war it
was the hard top models of the first
Volkswagen that rolled off the assembly
lines in Wolfe's pork in 1949 finally
the beetle cabriolet took to the road
and dusty McMahon had many were keyed to
get in on the action like the first 60
VW sedans the pre-war soft-top prototype
was built in the garage of Ferdinand
Porsches villa in Stuttgart at Basel for
the beetle cabriolet was always based on
the most expensive and powerful version
of the beetle sedan that was currently
available this model from 1979 for
example has the 1.6 litre engine from
the VW 1303 s which was first
manufactured in 1972 and was the most
powerful Beetle engine ever to go into
series production it goes from 0 to 100
kilometers in 20 seconds yeah nothing to
get excited about there but focusing on
power and speed was always a taboo for
VW their priority was reliability
that's a shame a little more power would
certainly suit the 1303 convertible the
1979 super beetle as it's known had the
best beetle suspension of all time
distinguished by a coil spring and strut
front suspension this car that is more
than 40 years old and with a pre-war
design takes bends with astonishing and
astounding ease either Kristoff says the
handling of the VW beetle is very
special the steering is unbelievably
responsive effortless because the engine
is at the back it powers the rear axles
in the wheels directly providing endless
traction as Porsche fans know this
design setup can actually handle a lot
more horsepower in fact the porsche 924
that was designed together with VW drew
on the beetle design now that has to be
the ultimate accolade for the beetle
suspension k 55 acres
the modern chassis that was introduced
to the VW 1302 in 1970 allows for more
space in the trunk thanks to the longer
front from 1972 the 13 03 came with a
taller curved windshield to comply with
US law which required a greater distance
between the driver in the windscreen the
modern style padded dashboard was
another concession to passive safety at
the rear an air-cooled 1.6 litre boxer
engine provides 50 horsepower
as I kind always said the exterior of
the 1303 convertible reveals little
technical progress there are a few
details like the chunky taillights that
earned the nickname elephants feet but
otherwise the basic shape of the VW
beetle hardly changed in 30 years of
production but in the interior there
were big changes introduced in the 1970s
plastic everywhere in those days that
was state of the art of course but today
you'd love to just have a little chrome
here and there instead but the robust
soft top design was retained the roof
can be shut and a few simple steps
keeping out that summer rain simple and
practical and [ __ ] [ __ ] tease
right from the start the soft top
version of the beetle cost around
one-third more than the sedan still
sales for the cabriole a boom for over
three decades Christophe says for cedar
convertibles have a long-standing
tradition in automotive history but in
the 1970s they were a dying breed with
just two models left the VW cabriolet
which sold for 14,000 Deutsche marks and
the rolls-royce corniche convertible for
180,000 Deutsche marks so you can guess
which model insured the four-seater
convertible survived rolls-royce old
3,000 cars in total while VW sold 20,000
convertibles a year thousand ho Yong
after more than 20 years of production
the beetle cabriolet finally reached its
zenith in the 1303 robust reliable
equipped with a modern suspension and
capable of a top speed of 130 km/h and
yet the Beatles days were numbered
dhanyavad for years the soft top beetle
was considered the world's best selling
convertible during 31 years of
production over 330,000 vehicles rolled
off the assembly lines only in 1991 was
it overtaken by the VW Golf when it was
announced in 1978 that production of the
beetle cabriolet was to end fans stormed
the VW dealers to snap up the last
remaining cars which is pretty rare in
the fast-moving automotive industry so
the VW convertible is definitely a
milestone in automotive history driving
with the wind in your hair the beetle
cabriolet proved convertibles don't have
to be an unaffordable luxury and in so
doing has guaranteed that the soft top
lives on